have you been looking for an excuse to  replay Bayonetta well you just got it  I'm Tony and this is your surprise  gamespot news update Sega just revealed  a surprise pc port of Bayonetta and it's  available right now this new version of  the game offers 4k and HDR support and  it's made to run at 60 frames per second  with unlocked resolutions grab it before  april twenty fifth and you'll get  upgraded to the digital deluxe edition  for free that includes a five-song  soundtrack sampler wallpapers avatars  and a digital art book not bad for  twenty bucks and don't forget to Like  and subscribe to keep up with all the  best PC ports Bayonetta originally  launched in January 2010 on xbox 360 and  ps3 and GameSpot awarded it a solid  eight out of 10 so if you haven't played  it yet this pc version sounds like a  pretty darn good reason and for some  more sweet pc gameplay you can check out  our coverage of the dawn of war three  open beta  [Music]